of non-fiction books all weekend every
weekend
on book tv
next this week's encore book notes
presentation features historian john
keegan on his book a history of warfare
the goal of this book was to summarize
the story of war over the past forty
thousand years
on this veterans day weekend encore book
notes presents this hour-long
conversation originally aired in may of
1994.
john keegan author of a history of
warfare did you start working on this
book oh
40 years ago
when did you first get interested in
warfare uh
i couldn't help being
interested uh
right here uh 50 years ago when i was 10
years old the place was alive with the
apparatus of war
we were all interested if you were 10
years old the streets were crammed with
many american soldiers
soldiers anyhow but mainly american
soldiers american equipment
uh american airplanes have had quite a
lot of british airplanes too but
thompson where we are now was almost an
american town
uh in
april may and
the beginning of june 1944 they were
waiting to go to d-day and this was the
this was one of the main
american concentration areas what do you
remember from those days
uh jeeps
jeeps are the thing i remember most um
because nobody in england had ever seen
anything like a jeep and if you were 10
years old it made an even stronger
impression
uh every
10 year old english boy wanted to have a
drive in a jeep and i did get a drive in
a jeep too which was a tremendous
excitement
but i i suppose it's very difficult
not to impose particularly if you're a
historian not to impose your
subsequent memories on what you
actually do remember but i do the
americans
were different i think they were of
course different to older english people
but they were even different to
to english children
they were american they weren't they
were much more extrovert and cheerful
and
good natured and uh
everything that americans are supposed
to be and that that is very strong
impression from those times
what what was this area used for as far
as staging is concerned but why was the
military here there was an enormous
hospital here you see the the the
everybody all the commanders eisenhower
montgomery they all expected very heavy
casualties on d-day
they thought there would be tens of
thousands of wounded on the beaches
and that they'd have to be treated um
here back here in britain said
the americans because this was an
american area they built an enormous
hospital here
and it still exists and it is taunton's
main hospital it
uh
uh it shows what american prefabrication
of 50 years ago could
could do
and it was a supply area and there were
airfields there were uh glider airfields
for taking the the the glider-borne
infantry to uh
to um
the whereabouts of samara glees
where the 82nd and 101 airborne
divisions were going
um and i think there was just everything
really um
i would have to reconstruct some sort of
map which probably be difficult to find
nowadays but to a child's eye that was
everything how many books have you
written
uh
counting sleight of works about 20 i
suppose
which one's done the best
uh
face of battle which i published in 1976
in a curious way it's always called a
classic so i suppose it is a classy
um
what i put
it
was not a difficult book to write i knew
exactly what i was going to say before i
began it just came out
it was not a difficult book to write in
the way that this was because
i
[Music]
was trying to put
so much that i know
into such a small space in the history
of warfare
your books do better in great britain in
the united states united states without
any question accept curiosity for this
one this one's been enormously
successful in britain and has won a
major literary prize
but i have a great american readership
uh it's not the only reason i
love the united states but it's one of
the reasons why do you think you appeal
to uh americans
um
[Music]
i don't know i went to america when i
was very young and i've been there many
many times in my life and i think
um i've got a feel for america it's
certainly a country that i'm
deeply devoted to tremendously
interested in
that's not really an answer to the
question
i think americans like
they like
the practical
they like the human
and i
like both those things myself and i try
and put them into my books i like to try
and pick problems to pieces in a
practical way
and also pick them to pieces in a human
way
and i think that's perhaps
it's not a deliberate formula but it may
be
the a formula that appeals to american
readers
you can't pick up many of your books
without learning that uh you're right
that you have a limp
well it's getting worse
what's it from uh it's from
orthopedic tuberculosis which is a
lot thank goodness is a
banished disease now and everybody gets
it but it was very common when i was
young
uh i attacked attacks the bone joints um
and
it leaves you damaged in somewhere
rather
when did you
contract the disease
just the end of the war and
just before they invented the drugs
which
um cure the disease about two years
before doctors look at me and they say
you were unlucky
weren't you and i said yes another two
years and i would have been cured what
impact has it had on your life
um i don't in a cure i'm beginning to
regret it now because i am getting
rather lame in in in my i'm going to be
60 this year um
and the last year it's been a nuisance
it hasn't been a nuisance the rest of
the times it hasn't scarce effect in my
life at all
and in an odd way it gave me a very
strange
teenage years because i was in
flat on my back in bed for year after
year
and
in a ward full of young men who'd come
back from the war
um
i didn't regret that in an odd way uh i
didn't get a proper education
but i did get a strange sort of
view on life and i think people have
it's commonly said that people who've
been ill in childhood and have had an
upset education
uh never really regret that they do
unless they were absolutely deprived of
course i wasn't deprived but it's um
[Music]
uh
i think it's so
i think it's a spur to a writ not
not that one should claim originality
but i think it it means that you don't
look at the world in the way that other
people do and perhaps if you're inclined
to be a writer that's a help
why do you mention it in your books
sorry why do you mention the lamp in the
book because um
i'm a military historian and i've never
been to war and there must be some
explanations there i've never been in
the army i've never worn uniform i've
never been in the navy or the air force
i have to have a reason
uh i have a very good reason that which
is
the medical officer the uh
the
army
recruiting
center took one look at me and signed me
off
i mean i'm completely unfit for military
service
when did you know then
that you wanted to write about war
i don't know i think that it was this
wartime thing of being here just before
d-day and seeing these extraordinary
things
happening
um
i i was all
why are people interested in history
little boys some little boys are
interested in history some aren't i was
i'd always been interested from you know
from five or six i can
remember
liking
sort of child's history books more than
the other sort of child's book did
parents uh talk history my father was
very interested indeed um
and uh had been a soldier of the first
world war and that was an influence but
besides that i can't really explain i
you have to choose a subject eventually
if you go to university which i did and
i chose history i was i was what i was
interested in
and then you had to choose a special
subject
uh a major i suppose and i chose
military history because that seemed the
most interesting thing on offer and then
i got stuck in a groove
where'd you guys go
oxford
what school which college a bagel
now is there something special about
burial that does deals with history
it's got some very distinguished
historians it's also got a very strong
pacifist tradition and anti-war
tradition too
so that made me a bit of a an oddity are
you a pacifist
uh 95
what's the five
there are certain wicked people in the
world that you can't deal with except by
force
the most wicked in your lifetime
hitler without doubt i think that i
think hitler was seriously seriously
wicked um
not mad
twisted
uh
a lot of the bolsheviks were simply
dreadful to
might say to him that's terrible
the
great men of power who seek to change
the nations they belong to usually are
pretty terrible people
that five percent uh then allows what
uh i if you it allows the use of
uh for uh extreme force
um in a measured way
if possible in a measured way in order
to
uh curtail or
or extinguish the activities of these
wicked men we're talking about
you have a couple of figures in your
book um the history of our history of
warfare
by the way just a quick question why
didn't you call it the history of work
um i don't think there is the history i
think there can only be
histories each one of which ought to be
called a history because
ultimately it's a personal view
you pointed out earlier in the book
that some 20 million people had died in
the first world war
and another 50 million in the second
world war
how
um but well of course in the first world
war they were mainly killed by direct
military action there wasn't much
collateral death as it's come to be
called i.e
uh bombing or
or
civilian deaths um
uh
as a byproduct of fighting on the whole
it was people in uniform who got killed
the
probably 10 million
uniformed
it's a bit difficult to
get it quite right
uh the others were the victims of
hardship privation starvation disease it
was a huge for example
uh
influenza epidemic at the end of the
first world war
which
would have come any higher
but had
uh a a a a a greater effect because
there was such malnutrition particularly
in in in central europe
but segmore
uh i'm afraid in the second world war
there are an awful lot of collateral
deaths i.e um
i mean what two million germans killed
by bombing
uh probably a million japanese killed by
both civilians we're talking about
civilians killed by bombing
um
civilians
find themselves in the direct
line of fire for the first time
in
in the warfare of civilized nations
really
um and then there was a lot of um
again a lot of
death through private malnutrition
and war-related disease but also of
course a lot of uh
atrocity
of course there was
the deliberate genocide of of the hitler
genocide policy against
the jews against various other
nationalities uh minorities who were on
his black list but there were also there
was all they're also the atrocities of
partisan warfare particularly in eastern
europe
and in china
uh i think you probably you'd probably
get 10 or 15 million battle deaths uh
and the rest would be collateral deaths
civilian deaths what's the a the years
range for your book
from
the stone age to modern times
which is how many years
well
homo sapiens you and me homey sapien
sapiens has been about for 40 000 years
and that's it's the last 40 000 years
really has there ever been a book
written like this
one or two um
[Music]
but
not many people have had a go at the
whole thing
it is it is a bit arrogant
arrogant oh yes i think so
why do you say aryan
well you have you're pretending that you
uh
inevitably you're pretending that you
know
most world history which i clearly don't
you have chapters that say flesh
iron
and stone
how did you block out that book
i blocked it out
over a very long period thinking about
it thinking about i wanted i suppose i
eventually wanted to write to try and
put this extraordinary phenomenon i mean
men killing other men and sometimes
other women too not not very very
infrequently women killing men except in
the home of course but
not you know not for public purposes uh
very rarely women killing women men men
killing other men really this
extraordinary phenomenon why does why
why does it happen um
i wanted and how long has it gone on and
have the motives changed and clearly the
methods have changed would have the
native stream i i
i want i think i wanted to do it
i think i wanted to do it before i knew
i wanted to do it but eventually i knew
i wanted to do it
and
that meant beginning beginning
right at the beginning and it also meant
having some
means of organizing
it
and if you can't do it chronologically
if you start at the beginning and go on
to the end century by century um
the book could be that thick uh you had
to have some way of
uh
chopping it down um so i in the end hit
on the idea of
what was
the dominant
technology really it's not a technology
book but i really
in the end that i thought that was the
only way of simplifying organizing it
so stone weapons
and then there's this long period when
weapons have appeared but
the the
real instrument of war is the horse
from about a thousand bc to
1080
bit longer maybe there were what two
thousand years when
the horse peoples were the great
warriors of the world and dominated them
dominated every bit of the world where
you could keep large horse herds
luckily you can't in western europe
but uh elsewhere they dominated
where do you find
uh
if there is such a place the bulk of
the background material needed to write
some book like a book like this
well for years i taught at santos which
is britain's west point
uh
which has
the most wonderful i mean truly the most
wonderful library
uh it's a library whose origins go back
into the 18th century
uh it's housed in a very beautiful
building
it has very liberal rules about
borrowing and
working and that sort of thing it is as
far as i'm concerned the perfect library
and uh most most of what i know in life
i learnt in the soundhouse library where
is santa it's just outside london
about 20 miles west of heathrow
to orientate uh american travelers to
this country how big is it
it's uh
it's
it was built in the just at the end of
the 18th beginning in the 19th century
and a very beautiful piece of
parkland um
it's looks like a gentleman's mansion
the old building
it looks as though it ought to have
fallow deer grazing in the in the park
it almost does not quite
uh it's got
a bite it's about a quarter the size of
west point it has less than a thousand
cadets whereas of course west point now
has over four thousand cadets
uh and uh it is not
as uh it's the the
west point has a simply enormous
uh training area in which it sits
sandhurst has gradually lost that as
london has crept out towards it
but it remains accuracy a tranquil oasis
in
spreading suburbia how long did you
teach there 25 years very
far too long nobody should teach
anywhere for 25 years but what did you
teach in military history
exclusively again they should teach
military history for 25 years i did why
did you do it it's interesting i love
the place i like the people
um
it's one of the most beautiful places
i've ever seen on earth curiously it has
got a strange theatrical quality to it
um
my children were very happy there we had
eventually we graduated as
people do from very from
very humble married
quarters we went up the scale eventually
we lived in a very nice house the
children
uh we had four children who grew up
there and i think they loved the
surroundings my wife didn't but
[Music]
she gave in because
the children liked it and i liked it and
so i stayed
but i kept on saying to myself as time
went on
i'm i must not
uh i must not uh stay here forever
uh otherwise i shall become a vegetable
and i think i nearly did when did you
leave
in 1986.
then what
well the friend of mine uh who
uh a fellow military historian although
he was he
was
also an extremely successful and
well-known journalist called max
hastings telephoned me one day to say
um that he'd been offered the editorship
of the daily telegraph and did did uh he
think
did i think he should take it so i said
well max you
don't definitely think
uh
uh you need to ask me that question
and uh anyhow a conversation developed
in the course of which he said you know
if you'd like to be
the defense senator when i go to be
editor why don't you come so i said yes
and he said well i'm going to see the
new owner and i'll telephone you in two
days
uh
and he did and he said if you want to
come do come and that was the end of it
you're
sitting in a room that's a couple hours
from london do you do you operate from
here as a
daily telegraph defense correspondent i
go to london about two or three days a
week and uh but now of course we're also
electronic that you can sit
you can sit in your house in the west
country and
type into the paper or fax into the
paper uh it's scarcely an impediment at
all now
this book a history of warfare is
targeted to what
audience who do you envision buying this
book well i hope my fellow historians
like it and some do and some don't but
i've never really written for my fellow
historians what i've always wanted to do
is write the sort of book which fellow
historians would have to
take seriously
um but which was really
a book for the educated general reader
who
would like to
be informed to have his view of the
world enlarged about a particular
subject
and i i think this is the highest of all
historical callings i utterly
i always despise and i think i do
despise the the
the um
direction that
university history writing has taken in
which
a normal enormous effort and years of
work given to writing books which
really only interest
a few hundred others
uh address problems which only if a few
dozen others are aware of as problems at
all
and increasingly use language which
perhaps only other academics can
understand that seems to me to be
um
a perversion of the historian's calling
the historian ought to write for the
historian ought to be an educated person
writing for other educated people about
something which
they don't know about but wish to know
about in a way that they can understand
you put the emphasis a couple of times
on educated
what do you mean
educated
i suppose i would mean
what jefferson meant i i've got a rather
18th century view of what being educated
is which is
having read
um
the major works of literature uh having
uh
having an understanding of the broad
periods of history and which uh
the the world's past is divided perhaps
speaking another language or at least
being
uh aware of other languages um
uh and having some competence i don't
think
education having some special competence
that often goes goes all together too
but i don't think education
i don't look
to find an educated person in the ranks
of university graduates necessarily some
of the educated educated people i know
never been near a university
you had a book a couple years ago the
history of world war ii yeah
was that a different audience you were
writing for them than this one
not for me in fact my publishers then
rather marketed as such um
uh i won't complain because it's sold in
enormous numbers
but i i was i didn't think it was
aimed at a perhaps a slightly
i didn't say narrower market but uh
[Music]
no
one
what i think is this when i saw what the
book looked like uh it didn't
seem to be
the sort of manuscript i'd written it
looked a more popular book than i'd
intended it to be
klaus wits
the name is
almost on every page
how come
well i think perhaps i may have overdone
that a bit um but this awful
german who
died in 1830
born
1780
[Music]
he absolutely dominates um the way
uh
his military history is written
and what's worse state military policy
is formed
uh
he relentlessly argues that war is the
uh is the military is well the famous
phrase is war is the extension of policy
by other means the war is a form
is a
a form of political activity
um i did
of course sometimes it is but sometimes
it isn't i don't think that what's going
on in bosnia at the moment is
is political activity uh it's partly
political but it's
partly activistic as well people are
behaving in a
in a
in a way which
doesn't bear political explanation but
it does bear anthropological explanation
or cultural explanation what does
anavistic mean going back to
uh one's earliest forefathers
i think
i think um
uh
the mongols
or the
steppe turks who uh
who created the um well the step turks
who created the empire to which the
muslims in bosnia belonged
uh would understand what's going on
because they were violent
cruel
clever
[Music]
cunning people go back to classrooms
who was he he was a prussian uh son of a
clergyman born age 1780 served in the
prussian army
uh
captured by the french changed sides
when napoleon invaded prussia went to
fight for the russians
never made a great success for his
military career he was a difficult
cantankerous man he was regarded with
suspicion because he fought for the
russians even though
that was in the cause of prussian
independence
and he was sort of pensioned off sent to
the staff college to um
live out his days where he um sat down
and wrote this
great i mean it has to be said great
theoretical work
called on wall
uh which has influenced every
soldier
uh and statesman interest in war
for the last 100 years
recent times oh sure it's taught i mean
go into any of the united states
armed forces staff colleges and um
pick up uh the
the common curriculum and you will see
the name class of its half a dozen times
and they'll be causing this
discussion of
um
the uh
uh the uh
applicability of classifieds to modern
times very little questioning of whether
clausius was right or wrong clausewitz
is pretty well still gospel in service
schools in the
in the english and german speaking
worlds is he worth it
i think he uh
uh i think he uh well what i like to say
is that he doesn't describe war but he
perverts politics
in the beginning of the book you
dedicate uh
this book to winter bridgeman
who was he an ancestor i don't think
perhaps a direct ancestor i think more
kinsmen my mother's family were called
bridgemen
uh they came from uh
southwest ireland but they were
the sort of irish who
were originally english
the so-called ascendancy they they came
as conquerors and they were given land
um my the other half of me the keagan
half of course were the lot over there
[Music]
in the first place and who on the hill
got land taken away from them why'd you
pick him
international sort of i wouldn't call
him a mercenary but international
professional officer who
sailed his services he died in the
service of the french
there are an awful lot of people like
him in the book i think these
international professional
uh military experts uh are enormously
significant in the in the history of
warfare particularly in carrying skills
technologies too but particularly skills
from one society to another and
transforming them military
you say in the uh in the introduction of
the book that war is wholly unlike
diplomacy or politics
because it must be fought by men whose
values and skills are not those of
politicians or diplomats
explain
well i think first of all people who
undergo professional military training
like west pointers and people who go to
south house do turn out different
it's a more complete
training education there isn't really a
good english word there's a very good
french word a french say formation
i think the people who go to west point
or sanchez literally are formed
or and transformed and they become
different from others they uh
they have automatic uh
reactions of duty and
meeting standards which the rest of us
don't that's one thing
the other thing is i think that inside
this group there is and you don't
necessarily
find them inside the professional
military group you can find them outside
too but
inside this professional military group
you do find
people who just
you cannot imagine in any other setting
they just seem to be warriors and they
seem to be recognized by the others as
natural warriors
it's a bit like saying um
asking asking how to identify them is a
bit like asking how to identify
supremely
handsome or beautiful human beings you
can't
but when you see them you know them
they're there i think
if you could observe them in action
you would understand and be able to
describe but
because of the secret nature of warfare
you can't but they are like those
sportsmen who can't be anything but
sportsmen
and who you can identify because you can
see them running faster than anybody
else or or
[Music]
playing games better than anybody else
you uh right below that say
war is
wholly unlike diplomacy or politics
because it must be fought by men whose
values and skills are not those of
politicians or diplomats no what's the
difference between the values of
politicians diplomats and soldiers
oh so
it's a necessary quality of a diplomat
or a or a
politician that he will compromise and
indeed
we we on the whole don't want to be led
by uncompromising politicians or
diplomats
they'd get you into the most terrible
trouble
on the other hand soldiers among
themselves when committed to a task
can't compromise
because um
they may that is that
compromise it's the opposite on the
battlefield it's compromise it's
compromise which will get you into
trouble
uh it's only unrelenting devotion to
uh the standards of duty and courage
uh
uh
absolute loyalty to others not letting
the task go until it's been done that
that will get you through that's why
they're different
i
want to ask you about some wars that the
americans have been involved in and get
your analysis on what was the vietnam
war all about as relates as it relates
to history
um
i would never oppose the vietnam war um
i thought that the americans were right
to do it
i think they fought it in the wrong way
but i think that they were right to
to oppose
the attempts by uh gig
by ho chi minh and gap to
to make
the whole of vietnam into a marxist
society
um and looking to looking at what's
happened
to the country since i still believe
that it was right to try and stop them
i think it was
a responsible
effort by the united states
they fought the war in the wrong way
uh they fought the war with uh
in particular that what was wrong about
it was that they only sent soldiers
there for one year
so it couldn't be
run as a proper war it was uh it was run
with one eye on public opinion the whole
time
let me go back to your thing about being
a pacifist is that your five percent
coming out
yes i
i
i wouldn't have felt it was the end of
the world if the vietnam war hadn't been
fought
uh
it's not that kind of war i don't think
it's a war like fighting hitler
um but i i think it was a a
correct war right war and i i
i it's it had
indirect effects of the greatest
importance as well i think it
demonstrated to
the russians of the
russian leadership of the last years of
communism that
the americans were serious when they
said that they opposed communism
um
and i think it therefore contributed
eventually to the end of the cold war in
the fall of the
fall of
communist regimes all over
central and
eastern europe let me ask you about
terms did the americans lose the vietnam
war
ultimately yes i think they did
did general zap win
yes oh he certainly won
how did they do it against
what was rather expensive military
machine
uh they did it because they did not send
young men to war for one year they sent
them south
uh
50 000 i think it was every year they
sent fresh
i i may have got that thing wrong it may
have been 250 000 every year they could
send out to their young manhood they
could send that number south and they
didn't come back
until the war was over they either got
killed or they
went on it was an extraordinary
effort of national determination it was
really national determination against
only semi
national determination
why was general's app successful with
the branch
same thing
although he was up accuracy in some ways
against a more purposeful army because
the french
the french did not
go for one year they went for long tours
um
but in the end of course they were
outnumbered the
the
the french could only they couldn't send
conscripts to vietnam they could only
send regular soldiers and uh
um mercenaries from africa and
uh mainly africa
you talk a lot about mao zedong in the
book but don't mention we you do mention
him don't mention a lot about ho chi
minh well how does he fit in in world
history um i didn't go i didn't mention
ho chi minh and yup because they are so
much the pupils of mount saito
[Music]
particular methods were you didn't need
two more examples
had this extraordinary idea of
politicizing
sort of militarizing
uh politicizing and militarizing
uh very
ordinary humble people who stood on the
margins of chinese society
and of
attacking the centers of chinese power
from far away from uh
by indirect means
whether the thing would have worked if
the japanese hadn't knocked the stuffing
out of chiang kai-shek and the chinese
national army before my teeth got going
in 1946 i don't know i suspect that mao
owes a great deal of his success to the
japanese but even if he even if that's
not even if that is true
he nevertheless
his message was
sufficiently correct
and certainly
sufficiently powerful
to do enormous uh damage elsewhere
outside china in in vietnam for example
uh and and then later in north africa
and in a black africa
going back to klaus woods uh if you
would have found hitler and his den
reading
about war would he be would he have read
class
in
in his last will and testament written
in the bunker in berlin with russian
shells flooding
uh he mentioned only one name and it was
the name of classrooms now if you could
see
you know when he was alive mao zedong
sitting somewhere reading about war who
would he be reading i don't think he
would i think he'd been reading the
great chinese classics sun tzu
and ko who say
different things i mean
was not classification he said
what the great chinese classics have
always said
that it's better not to fight that the
clever man achieves his ends without
violence that uh
a battle delayed is better than a battle
fort uh et cetera et cetera i mean the
china the chinese have a different
conception of war they in which time
rather than action is the
is the defining
dimension who is sensitive oh
he may not have existed he's a very
ancient um
chinese writer of uh
2000 years bc
uh but he he he's the first to have
codified this chinese attitude towards
war which is uh
immensely
formidable if it's opposed by western
methods which are always looking for
decisions results thinks time is
precious
now if we could find you and your den
and your happiest of moods reading what
would you be reading
oh not military history i only do that
for work uh i
i
would be reading um my favorite english
authors and american authors who are
they
um
uh
depends where i am when i was at
princeton as a
fellow in 1984 by myself my wife and
children were home in england i became
afflicted by
cultural home
sickness and i read the whole of jane
austen in about two or three weeks again
um
but i wouldn't say i read like jade
austin in england curiously because i
live in such jane austen's surroundings
i don't need to
uh trollop particularly the anthony
trollop particularly the uh the church
novels rather than the political novels
uh kipling to whom i'm
absolutely devoted i think he's one of
the supreme geniuses of english
literature
um
for pure relaxation for when just to
sort of a sort of treat i look forward
to which will make me feel better in
life john buckin
americans
[Music]
hemingway
melville
i'm very keen on melville as a poet uh
whitman i'm very keen on whitman as
opposed
um
the
[Music]
the novelist of the 30s like like
steinbeck i'm there's
um
a
new yorker short piece writer hermia
dawg called joseph mitchell
whose works have just been collected and
reissued he's
um uh
it's called up at the old hotel i think
extraordinary pictures of americans show
my life
um if you're reading
military history
there's there's an american
called john will martin who's only ever
written one book
who i enormously admire i wish he'd
write his second book his first book is
one of the greatest influences on me
that there's ever been it's called
gunpowder and galleys and it's
about uh
mediterranean naval warfare in the 16th
century absolutely astonishing book
um what about
class
sun tzu
karl marx
just read them because i have to
let's work
uh
no i uh
i very much
uh
barbara tuchman who's you know the guns
of august uh i think she's a wonderful
writer at the sort of level i admire
sort of an expert who writes for other
educated people at a not quite expert
level i think that's tremendously
important
go back to the the pacifist thing
we took a tour of the imperial war
museum in london and our guide was a
pacifist
you write about military history and
you're a pacifist not quite not quite
five million
uh
you're the defense editor of the daily
telegraph what's the politics what's the
what's the mill what's the slant of the
daily telegram it's the uh conservative
newspaper i mean it is although not
officially the
the party newspaper of the conservative
party it is it is regarded as being
the uh
um the ark of the covenant of
conservative opinion in this country
does that make you a conservative
i'd
did that conservative in the last two or
three elections i haven't always voted
conservative i
um
the the alternatives aren't much
of an attraction at the moment in this
country but i'm
i'm i'm not a member of the conservative
party correct the image then the uh the
image of a conservative is pro-military
sure
does that make them i mean
american conservatives hearing you say
how could he be a pacifist
almost and be a conservative at the same
time
uh no difficulty at all um i i'd
uh i i think that uh a prop
even a pr pacifist i think should admire
the military virtues should admire
and indeed the best pacifists have those
virtues themselves
uh self-abdication and willingness if
necessary to sacrifice their lives what
they believe i mean that is the ultimate
military virtue that i will lay down my
life if called upon to do so it's a
duties not obligate that's ultimately
what makes when i say soldiers are
different that's what ultimately makes
service different that
i won't choose whether i will or not lay
down my life
i have already promised that i will it
is for sworn it is given away i will say
a soldier has mortgaged his life
he said here is my life and uh i can
only have it back again when
the end of my service comes and
i
um salute for the last time and take my
pension
i think a pacifist is the same except
perhaps he's his willingness to
sacrifice his life never goes
this is your 20th book you say
where do you put it on
the list of your personal favorites
uh i enjoyed writing it enormously more
than anything i've ever written um
when i wrote the face of battle i felt
i knew what for the only time in my life
i knew what kipling meant when he said
that a sort of dime on a sort of spirit
descends
and you the book your pan moves
in
in an
uh
unconscious way i didn't feel that with
this it was an effort but i still
enjoyed writing it very much indeed how
do you write
now increasingly by pen i've got uh
every sort of writing instrument known
from
a word processor to a to a fountain pen
and a marvelously
uh unreliable uh 40-year-old portable
typewriter which i do like writing on
but i increasingly i write just with a
fountain pen
in income lined
paper
compared to what earlier i used to type
on on my on my portable
i did have an electric typewriter once
which um
was a monstrosity why'd you change
uh
i sorry to bring it back again i just
get backache now if i type for long
periods so it's easier to
it's easier to write with a pen
where do you write
in
the room at the head of the stairs on
the second floor of my
house in the country looking out over a
very beautiful garden my wife's created
towards
the edge of
the chalk
plains of saulsbury plain at
an iron age fort which was put
dug by the
celtic people of britain then perhaps
the century before
caesar conquered the island oh he didn't
before augustus conquered the islands in
43 a.d does that make a difference to
you where you are yes i'm very conscious
of that in front of the house just a few
hundred yards away runs a a primitive
track quake called the hard way which
alfred the great brought his army up
from the from uh somerset to fight the
danes at ethan dune in in the 9th
century that means a great deal to me
wendy right
all day 10 o'clock in the morning till
7 30
at night with a short break for lunch my
wife is a writer to say we
don't she doesn't object too much
objects a bit what does she write she
writes civilized books
um
biographies of
she's she's wrote a biography of the uh
wife of the of
what compares her gustav mahler it was a
very extraordinary woman in her own
right what's her name by the way alma
mala my wife is suzanne keegan
and published in the state yes alma ma
her life of almana was a great success
and
she's now writing the life of the
painter oscar kakoska
who
was one of alma mala's many lovers
where did you two meet
uh in the house of a friend uh when she
was 22 when i was 24
what was the attraction she's very very
beautiful
what about the writing skills
that's a complete surprise to me and to
her i think um
uh she just started to do it one day and
it hasn't stopped
do you ever write together
she has a room we have a long long thin
house and she has a room at one end and
i have a room at the other end children
i have four children uh who i've read to
say all are more or less in our sort of
trade uh my
elder daughter was a journalist
uh
for the comedy nest organization married
an american
um
my
eldest son is a publisher
for simon schuster uh my youngest son
who is a twin
is a journalist and his twin sister is
an actress so i'm afraid that we're all
in the words business and what is your
future publishing plans in other words
are you with kanav for on a contract
basis i hope so um i don't in fact have
a client this was not a two book
contract but i i i i think there's no
doubt i
will uh publish for them to publish for
them next time raw and i think they'd
i think they'd have something to say to
me if i didn't
um
i
intend to write
uh the author who we all know is john
mccarry is a friend of mine
and he said after reading that there's
nothing in it about intelligence
military intelligence that is um and
that's planted a seed
i've seen this books
i'm not sure you want to hear this there
are stacks of these books in stores in
the united states assuming that a lot of
them have been sold before i got there
uh this seems to have been marketed a
lot at least around the washington area
how's it selling oh very well i think i
hope what does that mean to you how many
does it have to sell for you to say that
was a good one well um the
the second world war
sold in the united states in hardback
about uh between 80 and 90 000 and that
for history book is very very good
indeed if that does us well i shall be
very pleased could you make a living
just writing books oh i do
but you mentioned you were the daily
telegraphers i would only do that
because i would go mad if i sat at home
in the country and
wrote books or my wife would kill me um
i mean i
i work for the daily telegraph because i
find it extremely interesting to do so
but i am a professional book writer
you tell us in the conclusion of your
book that the future when it comes to
warfare is
brighter
um can you explain that
and i may be misquoting you but i know i
did i did i did i did
but i wrote that
two years ago
uh i don't like to see what's happening
around me really i think the world's got
i think the world's taking a very nasty
turn in two years
i don't like what's happening
um
i think there will may be a way out of
the north korean situation but i don't
like it
um
i think that they have to be prevented
from becoming a nuclear power
um that's the most pressing of all
problems at the moment
um
the
the situation on the fringe of
you know christian and muslim lands
running from
bosnia into the caucasus is extremely
unpleasant
and um
there's
i don't see i don't think we've seen
uh even the middle of it yet certainly
not the end
uh
i think that
black africa
is
uh
extremely
terrifying for black africa i didn't
think it would affect the rest of the
world unfortunately uh i mean i think
that's part of the tragedy that the
black africa can become
uh a milestone of uh warring tribes
without the outside world
needing to feel that it feeling the need
to do anything about it
uh except of course
for the armed salesman to
sell arms into into the situation
uh those are the those are the three
great
areas of uh
unpleasantness that
i
identify and which i think have all got
worse
since i since i finished rather
optimistically two years ago what caused
you to finish optimistically
in the first place well
i
finished writing that book in 1992.
and we were still very much celebrating
the end of the cold war
uh the war in civil war in bosnia had
not broken out um
there was nothing like the trouble that
there was in south africa uh we'd had a
very successful conclusion to the gulf
war which looked as if the u.n was uh
although not strictly a gulf war and not
strictly although the gulf wars it was
not strictly a u.n war it was fought
nevertheless with un approval
everything looked extremely
um
positive for the future of peacekeeping
by the responsible pers and it looked
too as if russia was moving from
uh
from
from its former
unhappiest
state into one of
equal stability with the other
uh large parts of the world
so i i think it was possible to be
optimistic
i'm still
oh far but fundamentally i'm possible
i'm
personally i'm optimistic but
there have been pessimistic erosions of
my optimism let me ask you this though i
mean you you wrote a book here a history
of warfare
you've written 20 books on history you
go back 4 000 years
what is it about today that ever made
you think there was a shot at this thing
worldwide long-term peace
because everybody forgets about nuclear
weapons i mean it's it's amazing i mean
you know the cold wars
berlin war lady came down in 1989
uh everybody knew about nuclear weapons
in 1989 1994 they all seem to have
forgotten about them i mean they're
still there
they're still threaten anybody who tries
to fight a really big serious war
with nuclear retaliation that's the
fundamental basis for
either
uh
genuine optimism or else uh
hopeless pessimism well i'm not prepared
to be hopelessly pessimistic i don't
think man's that stupid i didn't
i didn't think well even i
i i i can't see any
i can't visualize as the situation in
which we
nuke ourselves into extinction i think
we'd find some way of not doing that and
that being the case nuclear weapons
must be seen as a means of stopping big
wars and that is a great relief to
mankind sitting back uh early 1900s
would you have ever envisioned 70
million people killed in two world wars
not in 1900
um
i think in between the wars
20s and 30s
you hung on to hope for the world with
very very
sort of
fragile fingernails
uh
man got into the habit of killing people
in large numbers by pretty brutal direct
methods in the in the 20th century a
civilized man did and nuclear weapons
said
right
you go on like this look what's going to
happen
uh but near the end if if you had to
pick a
military
offenses and who would you pick uh
wellington
the first duke the great duke because
you all they're an amazingly successful
soldier
never really defeated he had a
a
an extremely
[Music]
sustainable
attitude to war really
i think he thought he was a necessary
evil he happened to be very good at it
but i don't think he he didn't glory and
more
uh he thought war was pretty horrible
but sometimes you had to do it
and
uh the
i'll also he was a superb i think a
fascinating
example of a particular human type he
was sort of the ultimate ideal of the
western gentleman
uh
the other would be eisenhower who i just
was simply because i admire him
enormously as a human being
um and he's
if wellington epitomizes
the sort of english gentleman
um um
eisenhower
epitomizes the natural american
gentleman the the farm boy who
uh
who with a with a
a
um
a sort of religious upbringing by a
deeply religious mother who who uh
nevertheless is sort of quite a
character a small town boy
goes to west point
[Music]
uh acquires an education
uh
and then through responsibility
becomes an extraordinary
uh extraordinary sort of agent of power
throughout the world
and yet never loses touch with his roots
in in cancer so he is he's a remarkable
achievement
he's very wise
and good man i think a deeply good man
and
good men who exercise power are really
the most fascinating of all people
john keegan we're out of time thank you
author of a history of warfare
thank you very much indeed
a history of warfare was originally
published in hardcover in 1993 and is
still available in both hardcover and
paperback
every weekend book tv brings you an
encore presentation of c-span's
booknotes program